tonight parents will meet in what they
call a movement to break up ccsd
this comes a week after the district
opened up in-person learning
through the hybrid model madison
kimbrough has the latest from henderson
yes tonight's meeting is a call to
action urging governor sysolak to change
the way the district is organized
something parents say has been an issue
for several decades
the goal is for the district to be
broken up to more localized school
districts instead of one massive one
ccsd is the fifth largest in the nation
with over 320 thousand students
with the amount of kids in the district
parents claim it makes it hard to manage
which is why many believe so many
students haven't returned fully back to
the classroom
jenny lynn eddington who used to have
her two children in the clark county
school district explains
we will be meeting together and rolling
out a strategy
to let sisalak governor sisolak know
what we're asking of him
we want him to know that we're not
satisfied being
among the worst states for education
we're not satisfied with that and we
feel that if
there was a smaller school district then
we would be able to
solve some of the problems and the
problems would be managed
better and we could have gotten the kids
back full time
safely more earlier than they have been
eddington and several other parents have
created a facebook group where they post
about their next events
and plans moving forward so far since
starting a couple weeks ago
the public facebook group known as
breakup ccsd
has already gained thousands of
followers and tonight's meeting is
expected to bring 80 to 100 parents and
that starts at 6 30 tonight
reporting in henderson madison kimbrough
8 news now